hello and welcome to this video playing
Italian masters what utter like him play
him for a while
what kind of a Syria oh okay hmm
interesting and you can choose your flag
completely to your liking so we have a
Queens gambit here Queens gambit
accepted with 96 I think you know was it
create Queenie - I think I don't know
this all that well have to admit
hmm isn't it takes you five a bit
annoying here hmm let's see the Queens
gambit accepted is something that I
don't have really have that much
experience with I've had it very rarely
in my tournament games extremely
extremely rarely and it's not something
that I've ever studied in detail 95
looks a little bit awkward here yeah
maybe not I don't know yeah he plays it
he plays it pieces look a little bit
uncoordinated
hmm that's not a good opening result
they're really not black it's perfectly
perfectly fine if I go something like b3
evil have a have a weak square on c3 so
Sam I'm playing Bishop d2 Roxy one okay
why not check made me please and that's
a good move problem I don't have a 4 and
g3 is Quincy six
a trip should take screen checks check
and then 95 at the end of the thing know
what is dog poo that means this is a
pretty awful position yeah it's just
pretty awful amazing how bad it already
is
yeah I played whoopsy want to cover this
for 95 95 22 I'm a tit
so I have to go somewhere else but I
don't really have a great square maybe
here maybe here okay he won't rate the
Queen's here but after Queen trade I'm
actually still alive but it won't happen
I guess I guess rather yeah where is he
going
Queen h5 maybe it looks like a brand
this this might might be still a game
yeah I be sure to 9f to take stakes then
both mine bishops skewered
we came this it's not this is not asked
it's not so terrible this position
before a success is somewhat weak and
it's not so bad
okay still but should be to look see for
can be an idea or just yeah let's just
bring this up Navin that's it hmm it's a
that doesn't that's not so that doesn't
have a clear purpose to smooth anyway so
let's seem maybe just this threatening
Bishop before it looks useful and it
kingi to wasn't really necessary
should be false my dear and threatening
bishop takes before then
should work
should welcome
maybe does not maybe does not
necessarily have to lose this but it is
pretty bad I have to be pawn of course
yeah I'm sorry yeah I have to be ponded
wins it was extremely lucky
I assume play simply was better was
worse I mean I don't know how much but
probably a lot this is just not a good
position I have really miss played this
opening and that g4 already was
extremely critical but at least I found
the best defense with Roxy one yeah he
is threatening Bishop III and Queen h2
and I cannot really do anything there
this is immediately lost and if I do
with this then I thought this is awkward
I saw this and then this I Bishop e6
okay I overlooked Bishop e6 then this
was maybe playable I was thinking at
five and I have no movement but I
overlooked that I can take this X okay
this is why I played this covering see
for a little bit better okay so this it
looks really bad but maybe it is not
that terrible I mean the computer kind
of confirms it does not does not give a
direct loss Queen h5 is better though
yeah yeah this is not a problem at all
yeah I mean oh this is interesting
I thought this wouldn't work this go of
course uh-huh
I can do this I have [ __ ] I didn't see
King in - I didn't see King it - bishop
a6 already worked ok at the back rank
the back rank
[Music]
yeah a five is a slowish move I wonder
whether where the problem was probably
right here route 67 okay yeah well here
here wine already wins yeah he doesn't
have anything against we should be
formed with it just it just you just
lost him yeah sometimes it happens yeah
you actually play a bad game and you
sort of kind of stumble your way forward
into a win and you really don't know why
you ever should win because you just
played a bad game but it works I still
have the stuttering camera why anyway
thanks for watching